I already know the answer to everything
it's just a question of getting to it
I'm Milton Glaser and I'm known as a
graphic designer
the issue about doing posters for urging
people to vote is that it's not enough
to say go vote you have to justify that
you have to tell people why they should
vote and that the why has to be a
powerful idea and I thought the idea
that voting is a manifestation of
existing and proving that you exist
because if you don't vote you're
essentially invisible and you don't
affect the structure of your own life or
anybody else's for that matter one of
the reasons that people don't vote is
they don't believe it will have an
effect and that is a great sadness
I have a hope that has in effect that
someone somewhere will be affected by it
and vote and if it's 10 people as better
if it's thousand people that's even
better
but the role of design is not to
persuade it's to inform if you try to
persuade people to do something that is
not in their own good you're committing
a dreadful act against the culture and
against civilization
you're doing something that is selfish
pigheaded stupid and ultimately
destructive the brain is a very valuable
instrument certain images certain icons
certain words have the power to
physically and spiritually change the
mind and it can be affected by colors
and shapes and sounds and images and
words in ways that we don't understand
art is essentially transformative a
single word or single gesture or a
single tool nor a single color can be
transformative